what is love to you well that's a really
big question how long you got I I I I I
I do think that I mean look we've for
the last like what 100 years in
Hollywood storytelling we've seen the
story of relationships beginning
and ending and very little in between
and the truth is like when you're young
the only models you have are the people
around you if your parents are together
great if they're happy great I mean we
know statistically it's not it's not
that common as it used to be so you know
you have the stories you watch and and
you have stories of intoxication like
basically love junkie yes you have
people seeking that experience and again
I think that's where Joe and his box
um our
our uh it's it's just it's just a
literal embodiment of that so for for me
the show has been a really interesting
experience where I have thought about
this a lot and I see how little what it
takes to sustain a relationship